tax day is on Tuesday while some people
rush to get it in time some lower income
families say they have a harder time
doing so but there's help for them this
weekend a news now reporter Ryan Matthey
takes us to Manny Cortez Elementary in
the East Valley oh I need this thank you
Ronnie Smith is overcoming the deepest
loss of his life he's trying to
recuperate from my wife passing away and
just being separated from my family
it's kind of hard the loss forcing his
world to flip upside down Landing in Las
Vegas without work now there's a
deadline I don't know how to do taxes
and I haven't done them in a while and
United Way of Southern Nevada says his
story is not that unique unfortunately
people get formed like this unsure what
to do with them and this weekend there's
help for them to prevent fraud and
that's why you owe that money free tax
filing help for low-income families
that's where we're going straight to
communities where we know that families
and individuals will appreciate it most
they can walk over to us we have many
clients who haven't done their taxes
since 2016 and and older years Magda
Lopez who's helping to file says big
credits from the pandemic are not that
big anymore this year the credits most
of them went back to the levels of 2019.
all the more reason to seek help so
that's a big risk and danger for them
right now because there's other
investigators Neil montemayer points out
low-income families are urgently turning
to last minute help that's not helpful
but if they're not properly licensed or
knowledgeable they could you know take
the person's money and not file the
paperwork or do it in a way that the
person who actually assigned which is
the person that wants to file their
taxes is liable and accountable and they
never see the other person again